in the movie Inception Saito realizes  that he's in someone else's Dream by  noticing that the rug is made out of  polyester not wool like in his real  apartment throughout the movie you're  constantly reminded that a dream is not  about the visuals it's about the feeling  when we're awake we perceive the world  mostly through our eyes but when we  dream our brains work more holistically  activating neurons for smell sound touch  and this is why we're able to recreate  impossible environments so quickly in  our dreams in architecture we have this  concept called haptic architecture  architecture that's meant to be felt  through the five senses by using natural  materials or textures or manipulating  light or nature and by doing this or  experience of the space becomes stronger  it gets more solidified in our memories  and in some cases it even becomes a part  of you